[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 as always my name is caleb
denby and tonight i want to have some
fun uh we're going to be a little bit
less focused on improving your
tournament chest a little bit more
focused on uh some fun chess
puzzles and chess positions that have
been composed throughout history
and the reason why i wanted to do this
tonight is because
it's december and with the holidays
coming up actually a number of chess
sites always publish some really fun
some really interesting uh chess puzzles
that you can do i think chess.com just
released a puzzler uh where mixed in
with chess puzzles they also have some
some fun
uh
other fun chess related questions like
that there's a close-up of somebody's
beard and they ask you which famous
chess player's beard is this stuff like
that so if you haven't seen that check
that out
i've also been really enjoying the chess
advent calendar by
magnus carlson's chess club the name
escapes me it's in norwegian just search
advent of chess and you'll you'll find
that one
uh and of course chess base has been
publishing uh december puzzles for for
christmas for for years now so in honor
of all the wonderful chess puzzles uh
being released i wanted to go over some
of the absolute longest puzzles that
have ever been created starting with the
one on your screen right here
so this one dates all the way back to
1860 uh and unfortunately it is not a
legal chess position um
we have the the correct number of pieces
technically um black has seven pawns and
two dark square bishops
white has uh
one two three four five six seven or
eight pawns and two dark squared bishops
so that that's why it's pretty clearly
illegal you know can't get two darts for
bishops and have all eight of your paws
but
it was composed way back in 1860 by otto
blathy it is i think affectionately
named
monster for how kind of grotesque it is
but uh this position here is actually
made in 290
moves so this is the one i'm to use to
introduce these kinds of puzzles and try
and understand how exactly
anything can be 290 moves long and still
solved by by humans so i'm going to give
you the first couple moves for free
but first let's just take stock of
what's going on in the position here
so black has a lot of pieces kind of
jumbled up around here but none of them
can can really move right this rook on
c8 is essentially trapped by its own
pieces same with this bishop trapped by
the on pieces here
and this knight could could potentially
move
and this rook could potentially move and
this bishop could potentially move
we also have this knight to worry about
and so we have to solve sort of all of
these problems and get black stuck so
that that's our first order of business
so to start with rook d one check is
going to be the first move of the puzzle
uh black has to block there's no other
legal move
and then after c4 check and king d6 it's
looking a lot more like
black's pieces are all incredibly stuck
now right the knight in the rook can't
legally move as long as the knight in
the rook can't move the bishop on d8
can't move as long as the bishop on d8
can't move the rook on c8 could only
capture on b8 which would give white a
queen and allow white to checkmate
similarly though we can't really move
either of these pieces because they're
both also hemmed in
this bishop is stuck making sure this
rook can't escape
and now
that just leaves this knight to take
care of so white's going to capture on
g1 we get bishop c3 rook back to d1
check making sure this bishop can't do
anything over here
uh bishop back to d4 and now we we
essentially have the uh the crux of the
puzzle here those first four moves are
just sort of the prelude to to the
actual puzzle
so the question is now
what can white do in order to to win
this position
and i'll give you a hint it has to do
with none of these pieces
being able to move uh without hanging
something so that's pretty much every
piece that that black has
so you don't need to give me a
you don't need to give me you know the
exact 290 move line
but let's let's throw out some general
ideas see if we can solve this monster
so there is a chess term that this
puzzle is going to revolve around which
you probably have heard of before
what was that
yes
i've never heard it called z-zuggy
before but yeah ziggsvan of course is
the idea and that is how we're going to
get these crazy move lengths in in these
kinds of puzzles there's some sort of
forced zugzwang that we can get black in
um
but because black has for example three
h puns
uh every time we force the zugzwang
position he's only gonna have to move
upon one square up the board so what
what's gonna happen is we're gonna find
a cycle that we can that we can move in
that gets black into zug's wong then
black has to move upon then we repeat
the cycle to get black and zugswang
again and then again
and then again and again and again and
again and again and again and again and
a few more times
until all of the pawns are gone
and then we're able to make progress uh
somewhere else
once we've removed all of those pawns so
once again i'm gonna highlight all the
pieces that can't move the pawns we just
discussed they're there to sort of give
black uh extra moves in our cycle so
what piece is it going to revolve around
aside from the pawns
for black one of black's pieces i have
not highlighted the bishop on a right
and so the key to this position is going
to be
winning the bishop on a8 such that we
can play a8 and make a queen
so
now we have our general idea we need to
put black into zugsvang
and then we need to be able to do that
over and over and over again
the question now
is how do we do it
how do we do it
so the chat's throwing out some ideas
that that aren't really zug-based but
anything you try to do like b4 or f6 or
anything like that the fact of the
matter is black just has way more pieces
than white and so you can sort of break
the uh the hold on the position but it's
not going to be favorable for you and
it's not going to be checkmate black is
going to
be the one breaking free and then once
these pieces can untangle
uh
maybe white's in trouble kind of i i
don't know
don't want to make too big of flames
so we need some way to put
black into zooxvon
so i'll give you a hint
imagine the current position except it's
black to move
is black in ziggsvang
now the chat says someone put this
position into stock fish
uh stockfish can't help you here i'm
afraid
270 is just just a hair outside of its
uh horizon
or 290 even made in 290.
so i didn't get an answer so imagine
it's black to move here is this actually
zhug for black
if if black had to move in this position
would he be zogged
and the reason is again none of these
pieces can legally move okay sides of
the rook beside the rook but that would
allow uh white to queen
um you can't move this bishop because
our king on b6 is guarding the only
square it would move to and that's our
eventual goal is to capture the bishop
so that means black now has to push upon
and so this is actually the first step
in the cycle achieving this position
with black to move
and so if you can figure that out you've
essentially solved the puzzle because
then you just do that over and over
again you find a way to get this
position with black to move over and
over again you just repeat the process
and then you win
uh so
let's try to lose a tempo shall we
so
what happens if we move
well first of all if we move uh any of
these pieces
we break our lock on the position right
we
lose everything f6 loses our e pawn our
e pawn can't actually move if we move
this bishop black again is escaping we
move this bishop black is capturing and
again escaping if we move this pawn
black is capturing and escaping with the
king and then escaping with the other
pieces
so none of these pieces are are going to
be good to move that leaves us really
with only two options we've got a king
left
and a rook that we can move so what
happens first of all if we happen to
move the rook
black would no longer be zugged right
because this gives him an extra option
so what option is that
the bishop exactly so we needed our rook
here to keep this bishop from moving
but uh now you know something like
bishop g7 would would be possible
so the trick is
um
we cannot actually lose a tempo with our
king because unfortunately we are
bounded on a straight line here so
there's no way to triangulate because
you don't have any square connecting two
other squares
so the trick now is going to be can we
use our king
to keep this bishop from moving so that
we can triangulate with the rook
and that is the core of this puzzle
and after that you guys will have done
it you'll have solved a 290 move
checkmate
so never say you can't calculate ever
again
so just as a visual aid here these are
the squares our king can feasibly get to
uh just because every other square on
the board is is attacked
i'm actually taking my jacket off here
it's a bit warm
so which of these squares look like they
might be useful
yeah brian uh
i mean i i was just thinking that being
on c2 would take away
right so if the king is on c2
and we move our rook
just imagine the king's here then bishop
c3 wouldn't be possible
but unfortunately bishop g7
and then maybe the best you can do is
come right back
and you have not lost a tempo because
you played direct f1 they played bishop
g7 played rook d1 bishop d4 that's just
repeating
um so c2 is not quite good enough not
quite good enough we need some way to
keep this bishop from moving at all
and i mean this bishop has a lot of
options f6 g7 h8
maybe it can even go to e5 i don't
actually know but i suspect it can
so how can we possibly immobilize the
bishop when it has so many squares to
move to
oh wait
we
we just bring our king to
one of the squares around b1 and then
and then we can play like with d3 if we
want to
oh okay that's interesting
so
what you say is true what you say is
true so let's go and put that on the
board
by the way um just just to i don't know
if i specifically mentioned this but
black is always passing with bishop b7
right so
i don't know if this was actually
apparent or not um and the point is
we're trying to to lose a tempo
so that we can play king b6 in this
position and black will not have the
passing move so black is passing and our
problem is even if we come all the way
down here with our king and then come
all the way back up
we haven't lost a tempo so we're ending
up just just repeating the position
right so that's why we're trying to lose
the tempo so we can try to win this
bishop
um
so king b1 and then you wanted to play
rook d3 which is now possible you are
correct
uh but the issue is
after bishop a8
you have not lost a tempo still if rook
d2 were possible then you could lose a
tempo by coming back in two steps but
the best you can do is play rook back to
d1
and again
just to show you haven't lost the tempo
if i come all the way back up
all we've done is repeat
so b1 and c2 not good
enough okay so the chat is pointing out
something interesting when the king is
on d3
the bishop can legally move but you have
a discovered attack with the king if the
bishop moves uh the bishop on d4 i mean
so if we put the king on d3 though the
question is why can't black just
continue to pass
or maybe he can
you guys are really close really close
almost solved all 290 moves or at least
the first 280.
yep about 285 more before checkmate
but you're almost there believe it or
not
do we bring our team down and then take
the bishop that way the bishop can't
move anymore
which bishop
uh i i was thinking
the deformation
so where do you want to put the king
queen
okay so the king on b1 and then take the
bishop
yeah so that that looks similar to the
b4 ideas where you're you know you give
yourself like an option to play b4 and
c5 after you take the bishop or c5 or
something but once this pawn disappears
then the king comes out once the king
comes out then the knight then the
bishop then the rook and the other rook
then
then you're you're stuck
so the sacrifice here is is no good
why not f6 if f6 you drop this pawn and
then again
the black pieces will flow
so maybe they put the king on e1 and
then
move the rope for example
and if he
moves the bishop for example to
g7
we don't have to react because he can't
take over this shot because he would be
mated
i suppose
right i agree um
so your point here is that you can
continue to pass yeah you can go
somewhere else
right so you're on to something because
if he if black were to come straight
back to d4
and you come back then you have actually
lost the tempo
right
here here bam black to move we've
succeeded
but the problem is black can be a bit
more clever
and just play bishop f6 or bishop h8 or
bishop c3 or probably even bishop e5
and so black will will also not step
back to the d4 square until you have
committed your rook to to check
yeah these are good ideas these are good
ideas
i think the the answer once you see it
you'll realize it's not quite as clever
as as you're uh you're hoping for
so what does this bishop do on d4 it
actually does something very really
useful for black aside from prevent
checkmate
well
actually that's that's kind of working
in our favor we want black to be almost
stalemated um so that we can force him
into zugzwang so black has to to push
the other things
all right i'm going to make it really
simple
it's protecting
those two pawns that maybe we could take
with a king right another square
exactly
um so not only another square but if one
of these pawns disappears black is
actually going to get mated in three
moves
so imagine the e3 pawn were off the
board
um white's going to play e4 e5
checkmate
and there's there's no stop in that
right
uh
there's just there's nothing to do if
the e pawn isn't there so it turns out
this e3 pawn is really really critical
and so we can use that to our advantage
to immobilize the bishop
which means we need to put our king on
which square
right
i
now again i might be speaking out a turn
here because i didn't check king e4
but uh it doesn't matter d3 is closer so
it takes less time
so of course we achieved zugswang by
placing our king onto d3 and now doing
what
our king is perfectly placed so the
bishop is immobilized
and that allows us
to lose a tempo so how do we lose a
tempo
what was it all for
for example
yep rook h1 rook f1 rook rook anywhere
basically i think in the puzzle
we did rook e1
uh now bishop c3 we would play king take
c3 and checkmate and bishop anywhere
else uh
even to e5 for example
uh we would play king takes e3 now this
would be a mistake it allows the black
king out but king takes e3
and here we still do have the immediate
checkmate
and if black doesn't sacrifice
then
again
e4
and let's say
we pin the bishop e5
that's gonna be checkmate that this is
actually checkmate on the board
um
so that is our key idea
so because we've done such a good job no
matter where this bishop goes
here and again now it's relevant that
someone uh in the live audience pointed
out we don't have to react to bishop g7
because this is checkmate we again just
capture the pawn
threaten rook d1 and then we have this
very easy checkmating idea which takes
far less than 290 moves
so of course the bla the best that black
can do now is to continue to pass
we take two turns with our rook before
returning back to d1 and then our king
makes the long journey back to a6 or a5
into b6
and we have completed the first cycle
we've achieved the same position black
to move and black now has to to move one
of the pawns
now
all we have to do
is do that about a dozen more times
like so
obviously you all saw all of this
and oh black had a queen there for a
second very exciting let's go back that
was fun
yeah so black slugged again now the
pawns do have to start sacrificing
themselves
and you can see that no matter what
black does he has to repeat and i'm
actually
testing the bounds of leeches studies
here they only let you import a pgn of
200 moves so we have to go to part two
where again you're just repeating the
same cycle
over and over again the h pawns continue
to drop
uh
king b6 the last h pawn falls very
exciting stuff
come back to d3 pass with the rook
go back to b6
oh and here we go yeah finally
black throws in the towel it doesn't
really matter what order black does it
here you give the last pawn
sorry
it's okay it's
not letting me edit that whatever
doesn't matter
you give up the last pawn or you give up
the bishop first and either way
you end up here
then finally
uh white is going to sacrifice on d4 at
this point this is just the fastest
checkmate it's not crucial that you
sacrifice or we know it is crucial that
you sacrifice on d4 otherwise black is
still mated then finally king b6 to keep
the king from running
uh forcing d3 after which we just queen
take take
take
and this is checkmate on the board on
move 290. uh that last bit there is uh
again the the only other unique part so
you have that unique part at the
beginning of the puzzle where you have
to get the black king situated on d6
then you have your cycle for about 280
moves and then you have the last few
moves of the puzzle sacrificing the rook
otherwise it is stalemate
uh king b6 to keep the king from running
to keep all of these pieces trapped
and then finally d3 queens
um threatening queen a3 i believe so it
takes takes and takes with with mate and
there you go
now you've all solved mate in 290 uh
and
incredibly yeah this this was composed
way back in 1860 uh which is why i
wanted to start with this
so that's how you end up with these
incredibly long chess puzzles almost
always it's because there is some sort
of of cycle going on like like this
where you end up in in zugsvang now
we're going to see some other puzzles in
a moment here
uh what was that oliver
isn't he going to claim the 50 move role
so
i might be wrong but i don't think that
we ever break the 50 move role here i
think um
let's let's see so
c4 captures so this was our last capture
on move three
and then black is forced to move the
pawn on move 21.
and i think our cycle is let's see how
many moves our cycle is so this is the
first first move
takes us one two three four five six
seven eight nine 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
17 moves to force the next pawn move so
this position winning even with the
50-move rule
uh but it's kind of a moot point
position's illegal anyways
uh but what i was saying is once we sort
of broaden our horizons a little bit
we're gonna find that um there are
positions that are incredibly long
checkmates that do not rely on these
cycles
um now i also wanted to highlight this
position uh from what i can find
this is the single longest checkmate
composed by a human
um
that is that has unique that is unique
and is legal this is a legal chess
position uh from what i can tell now
maybe the the serious problem solvers
out there or problemists will will
correct me on this if i'm wrong but this
one by walter jorgensen and therma dan
danicum uh in 1982 i believe this is the
longest unique solution legal chess
puzzle uh out there
um
and this one again is is going to rely
on those those sort of cycles i'm not
going to try to try to solve this one
with you i just wanted to highlight this
one and the idea of course is you start
with bishop h2
queen e3
and then we get in this little dance
with the king and the queen
and then we can finally make a move
and then we repeat
the cycle the little dance and then make
a second move
and then we repeat the cycle
making sure that black can't actually
touch any of the pieces
both the knights are paralyzed because
knight f6 through 95 would be mate if
they didn't defend the bishop and rook
can't legally move these pieces can't
legally move and so you have to move the
king
and this time what we want to do is
bring our king to d1
and i believe
this threatens checkmate if king f3 so
black can no longer pass
and this is the cycle that we get caught
in so we force black to move the pawn
now we come back and do this again
and finally we take the pawn now we need
to do this over and over again
forcing the pawns down the board
by the way
i should probably point out first
that's uh
way back here
black
or white should not capture the pawn
because then this is czech so that
that's why we need to force the pawns
down the board in the first place uh and
so long story short
uh 200 moves later you get to hear where
the final pawn is and then from here
you continue the cycle
and finally finally finally you play
king d1 for the last time black is
forced to move one of the pieces this
would be checkmate in one sonata fate
instead and it's checkmate in into
and there you have it that one i believe
is the longest checkmate composed by a
human that is legal
and has a unique solution
so you can prove that there's no
shortage
um no so that there's no
duals as far as i know i might be i
think that there are no dual solutions
meaning every move is forced uh by by
white if white were to deviate at any
moment then the solution would be longer
whereas there are other positions that
are longer than mate in 226 but white
has like a choice at some point you can
play either like king c4 or king b4 and
they are both made in in the same number
of moves okay so there's no starter
yeah there's no
well not only is there no shorter mate
that that's that's always uh
i should say is is usually true uh but
there's also no alternative mates that
are the same length any alternatives
here are going to take longer and not be
not be useful for white
um okay so with that i've had enough of
real chess real chess is dumb and i want
to look now at this position
so this one
you know i wasn't happy with uh with
mate in 270 i just wasn't happy you know
so i i wanted to to search
for
longer
and to find longer puzzles we are going
to change the rules a little bit
so this is not actually a checkmating
puzzle if it were a checkmating puzzle
it would be very very easy
you go c4 check
the king is in check the king must move
and then queen d1 is mate
mate and two not too bad uh but instead
the goal of this puzzle is to uh
self-mate now have you guys heard of
self-mates before
in the puzzle-solving world
all right so if you have not the goal is
to force black against his will to
checkmate the white king so black is
doing everything in his power to not
trackmate you that is his goal your goal
is to force
uh force checkmate of your own king here
with the white pieces
and again
what we see is that it's going to be uh
another cyclical
sort of zugzwang style style thing
now again i'm gonna get you started on
this one but i i wanted to show this
puzzle because i think it's actually
really really uh beautiful what has to
be done here so to start with we have
some preparatory moves where white is
trying to to capture some black pieces
just to get started
and this is just here to sort of extend
extend the length a little bit so to
start with
we capture the knight not on move two
when it's checkmate but on move three
when black has a response
then finally we can bring our knight in
take the bishop with check
um by the way we're doing all these
moves with check otherwise this black
queen would escape
then we are repositioning the knight
with check again over to f1
finally check check check check check
and
uh
i think we go through our first little
cycle here to come pick off this knight
on b7 black's pawns are going this way
of course
and then finally we're going to end up
back here
where we can play our our first move and
so
40 moves into the puzzle uh nothing just
at the very start here of course uh
white has finally captured all of the
necessary pieces it that white needs to
capture uh from black and then we we see
sort of the the core position here
so what's going on
well what's going on is that white has
successfully entombed the black queen
right this this queen has no path out
and if white is able to win the black
queen then white is going to have a a
pretty easy way to to checkmate himself
once the black queen is out of the
picture white doesn't really have
anything to worry about and can go about
checkmating himself in in a number of
ways i think i
uh
no i deleted the that that line where i
showed it but that's okay just just
trust me once the black queen is gone
then uh it's it's smooth sailing
for white
uh so now the task for white is to find
some way to
uh make progress from from here so black
is going to go king b2
we are gonna go through this entire
cycle one more time
and then the point is going to be made a
little bit more clear so yeah 96 is
important and
now let's try and find out how white is
is making progress here so
first of all let me explain what this
little cycle is a little bit better
so the point for white is that he wants
black to be completely immobilized aside
from the move king b2 and that way white
has time to to play a move so after king
b2 black of course is threatening to
escape and do any number of annoying
things so we have to check
and we walk our queen up the board with
checks
the point of getting to to the g7 square
is that allows us to finally check from
the front on the g file once we do that
we can force this bishop back to b2
then we walk our queen back down the
board using the same little technique
here again black's pawns are going this
way
we walk down the little staircase and
then finally we can repeat and once
again we have another free move so to
start with white plays this move knight
e6
and
now
let's see if you guys can come up with a
plan
uh to to make progress with white so
what does make progress means you're
making progress if you can capture an
annoying piece of blacks or make
progress towards promoting a pawn so
let's see if we can come up with some
kind of idea that makes progress here
so what might be useful for white
what might be useful here
attacking the queen
yeah attacking the queen would be nice
um
yeah so how how might you go about doing
that
yeah so knight f4 and this is uh that's
like first of all a fantastic idea
uh and there is just one problem with it
and the problem is
uh and this is why i wanted to show this
puzzle is the cycle that we're using
here requires
a very large portion of the board to be
open uh we need the queen to be able to
come to every one of these squares
over to b7 so these squares have to be
open as well back to g7
and then we actually have to walk down
this side of the board with the queen as
well
right uh that that last part of our
cycle there oop i skipped to move 200.
didn't mean to do that
um
okay
yes so once again just to show so we
walk up the board we're touching all of
these squares
then we need this rank to be open
and then on the way back down we're
touching all of these squares
um and d3 as well and d2 as well
in order to
repeat this cycle so the problem with
trying to step to knight f4 or knight g5
is that that's actually going to
interfere with the queen and you won't
be able to uh
to repeat this cycle anymore
also this bishop for the moment would
would be in your way
so let's say you try to do the same
thing here
and then you come knight f4
well first of all you can't do it in
this instance because you don't have the
queen on d1 and so the queen can can
kind of escape
so you would need to do it with the
queen on d1 sort of on
this tempo
come here
but then i believe
the point is king to b2
or wait maybe that's not the point okay
let me let me put it on the board one
more time
check check check here
okay knight f4
this is not an idea that i actually uh
came up with when i was looking at this
on my own so what's the deal with knight
f4 okay maybe
maybe black is just going to step out of
the way
i think that's that's likely the answer
here and once black steps out of the way
then unfortunately our cycle is is going
to break because we cannot
step to the f4 square on our way back
down the board
okay does that make sense
yeah took me a second to understand why
so once we achieve this position again
we need some other way
to uh to continue on
so once again we need all of these
squares
to be
available for the
for the white queen also we need these
squares available so that this move is
actually check and these squares
available here as well so that's like
almost the entire board
so what does that leave you to work with
what what's really left to work with at
that point
uh
so sorry our goal is to
win the black wing right now
well okay
you're thinking 300 moves ahead
um
right now we're actually i'm just going
to tell you we're unable to to win the
black queen with sort of our our
material on the board so what white's
goal in this puzzle is going to be is to
promote a pawn
uh and to recap one more time
white spawns are going up the board
black spawns are coming down the board
and our challenge is we are very very
tightly constricted because our cycle of
forcing
um
our cycle to give ourselves an extra
move
is taking up so much of the board we
need so much open space on the board
and so with these very limited
with this very limited amount of space
the question is how can we uh how can we
make any progress how can we promote a
pawn
so let's just start by eliminating the
the king side here so these pawns are
needed to keep this queen entombed right
we need sort of need these pawns here
not to mention if we move either of them
they're going to be interfering with the
queen
so what's left are these pawns over here
on the a and the c files so let's focus
on those and see if we can come up with
a plan
to promote anything
oh
yeah brian
like knight knight d8 c6 b8 a6
okay you make a good point uh and then
what would you do
after after that
which pawns are you promoting and how
just to show brian was saying maybe this
is a plan
avoiding all the important squares
and then get the night out get both
knights out of the way like i guess
um
bring bring it back
and then promote the a pawn
okay you make a good point which is
not good because it's incorrect and i
don't know
why um i think that we we need this pawn
on the board for some reason i'm
actually a little confused um
i don't know let's let's try it let's um
end here just just for the sake of
uh time i'm not gonna do the whole cycle
we're gonna just pretend that's uh
black is willing to play king b1 here
you know normally you would go through
the whole rigmarole of the cycle
uh to get this this position again but
yeah let's see what's going on here why
might this not work
uh okay let's say you play knight b8
and i try to continue the cycle here
let's see if black is gonna have any
extra opportunities
and if you see why this doesn't work
feel free to shout it out
let's see check
then we come this way
um
oh because you're not paying attention
oliver
um our goal is to get the white king
checkmated it's a self-made problem
okay
um so i mean these all have been only
moves unless i'm really missing
something here
so yeah what what's the big deal why
can't we uh why can't we do this
it's an excellent question i mean is it
does it take
longer no it definitely does not take
longer from from what i know let's see
it would be
one two three four five six
one two three four five six seven eight
oh this is very disturbing brian it's
very disturbing i didn't expect this
i don't know let's see if the chat has
any ideas for why this will won't work
interesting well we'll come back to this
idea i'll have to think on that um
because this does seem
like it would work it doesn't interfere
with any of those important um
important squares
and it does capture
uh the critical pawn
uh now the only thing i can think of is
maybe it's important that black has this
the c6 pawn for some reason i i don't
know why
uh what was that i mean because i don't
know the bigger picture so
yeah so we'll come back to it um
so there is another way to come capture
this pawn over here on
on a6
and that way
i'm just gonna reveal
unless anybody has less second guesses
yeah it's it's with the king so
um
we come all the way over
get the knight out of the way come
capture this guy and bring your king out
of the way and then we can promote the
pawn
so that's that's gonna be our idea so
let's let's jump ahead to uh to when we
can actually do that
um of course
play through the whole cycles here
moving our king one step at a time every
time we get that free tempo
then of course we can move our knight
out of the way
which yeah here it's it's important that
you play knight c8 not knight c6 so it
it does have something to do with the c6
pawn being important
um yeah i i think it has to do with the
c6 pawn being involved in an actual
checkmating position which is probably
why either it doesn't work or it takes
longer
so again we repeat the cycle this is
move 200. i have to move on to the next
portion
um we repeat the cycle take the pawn
repeat the cycle here
get our king fully out of the way just
to slow down
this is the position where we have the
tempo then we can move the king
and of course
now we get to promote our pawn so
skipping ahead till our pawn gets
promoted
that finally happens
on move 320 we get our second queen
and now white of course is able to make
a lot of progress so i'm gonna reveal
a few more moves here
before showing off the the checkmate
which i'm going to ask you guys to find
now our cycle is a lot shorter because
it's a lot easier to do with with uh
with a couple queens on the board
and yeah
finally let's get the king to b4
get our knight out
and this is finally the position where
uh
with two queens on the board white is
able to uh
to start harassing the uh
the black queen
so we play king b4 in this position
which we we normally haven't done
historically uh notably king to b2 is
illegal now so black has to make some
other kind of pass and in uh in the
in the best solution queen g1 is the
best that black can do
then that allows us to finally check
with the knight
and move our queen over such that we can
trade off the black queen and now the
rest is going to be
going to be history so i guess let's try
and find out what happens if black
doesn't play queen to g2 or queen to g1
i suppose you can play h3 but white can
just play a pass and then you play queen
g1 anyways
um
and then you get the exact same line
where we check do everything with check
notably don't play queen d1 here because
it would check mate black so you go
queen d2 then you get the black queen
off the board
and now finally
let's see if you guys can find uh can
find the checkmate
from
let's see
from this position
okay white to move
and get himself checkmated
and
no cheating here you can do it in just
two moves
two moves are all you need
queen
d7 okay black's gonna just move black
black will promote actually
by the way while you're thinking about
this i don't think i ever mentioned this
uh you know everybody loves hearing me
pronounce names i have no business
pronouncing this one was composed by uh
andre uh statsanko back in 2016 so
pretty new pretty new
uh and according to wikipedia this is
the longest self-made puzzle out there
but
i'm going to have something to say about
that i think wikipedia
either might be wrong or
someone with more knowledge than me can
can correct me afterwards
all right white to move and self-mate in
two
and i mean how can you guys not get it i
we've we've done 357 of the 359 moves
come on
yeah brent
knight c3 then queen d2
uh
and what is the checkmating move
and you want your knight on the c3
yeah
maybe
knight a3
king b2 queen d2
and
correct this is in fact checkmate
uh so there you go according to
wikipedia longest self mate out there um
and it's that simple
it's that simple
you just repeat the cycle a ton of times
if i can jump to where i had everything
highlighted
so i think it's because we
i mean we needed a king all the way over
there anyway so it's probably faster to
take the pawn
with the king because that has to
yes
so so that might be the case um but what
i wanted to point out here is uh
if
after king f8 if black were to sacrifice
the queen here there's actually an
entirely different
self mate that you end up going for
which i don't have the the line input
anymore i think i had that on a separate
uh
on an earlier version of my little study
here but just to show you what that
looks like i'm going to play
bad moves for black that are very
cooperative but if black sacrifices the
queen early
what white actually goes for
is and again
the moves i'm playing are ridiculous but
what white goes for is something
like
this where if i can just get my queen
out of the way
which is surprisingly difficult
okay
let's say my queen's out of the way
what you want to do is get your king
over here and you would move this knight
with check
um
and you would keep this bishop here for
for this entire thing you get the king
over to f1 you force black into
stalemate
and then
finally
you would check the king around the
board
until he has to come to f3
which is easier said than done until he
has to come to f3
you promote this pawn
and then you play queen g2 and so
the the point of that line uh obviously
that's not how you actually force it to
happen but you can force it to happen it
happens a lot faster than move 359 which
is why black should not go for this line
but the point is there are other uh self
mates available on the board it's not
like you have to do this thing over here
on the
on the uh on the b file
um
and
so that that's why i'm a little bit
confused i i don't know why this plan is
no good but i assume what you said is
correct where it's just faster if we
have the c pawn and we can get mated on
b4 and we can't really force that um
with the queen on the board
so interesting
so with that
there are two positions i want to show
you to end off on we're not going to try
to solve either
but uh i was hyping up uh all these
puzzles but of course computers once
again have far outmatched humans in
finding the longest chess puzzles ever
and the seven man table bases have found
a position uh this is that position and
white to move wins by force in 549 moves
in regular chess
so i wanted to highlight this one
because it is the longest puzzle of any
kind that i could really find while
prepping for this i'm sure there are
longer if you really broaden your
horizons and include you know like fairy
chest pieces and
ridiculous things but this position in
regular old chess white's move wins in
549
and to prove it the first six moves are
all pretty forcing
um
you go g7
and then with this bishop on f6 the best
you can do is promote to a knight
to avoid losing your queen and then
after king to e6 i don't know if we can
show this on the stream then but the
table base shows queen h3 distance to
the next capture is
1028 half moves so
there you go uh if anybody wants to go
through and put in all 1028 half moves
or what is it 514 full moves um that's
when the next piece gets captured and
then white ends up going on to uh to
checkmate from there so once again
computers just totally outmatching the
humans even with our stupid zug's long
cycles
we can't create a position uh like like
this where it's white to move and win in
549.
so there is this position and then this
is where i am challenging
um the viewers at home uh to help me out
with something here because
in
my you know admittedly not not
the most thorough research i came across
this position uh which was composed by
william shinkman back in 1907
and
i just found this on like there's like a
google
you know book archive of it and then i
found it on some like you know online
library thing maybe i'll post a comment
after after the class here on the
youtube video so other people can see it
as well
but william shinkman published this and
he says that this is a self-made in 418
moves
and i went through some of the lines and
what what he was saying seems to make
sense
obviously we know more about self-mates
in 2021 than we did back in 1907 so i'm
assuming he was wrong for some reason
and at some point in history this got
refuted as a puzzle but if true this
would then be the longest self mate
that's uh that i know of it's far far
longer than that 359
cyclical thing and just to show you the
idea here basically the way that this
puzzle works is we
slowly but surely force this knight to
move around the board uh first i believe
in the solution he forces it over to h7
so that it's out of the way
then uh he uses discovered checks to
move the king one square at a time over
to h6
then he forces this knight to come out
to h3
and then lastly i'll show you the finish
and how it all comes together uh once
white has officially organized all those
pieces but just to give you an idea of
how it works i'm gonna show you the line
that he gave that moves this knight the
first square then i'm gonna show you the
finish as well so to start with every
move played is a check otherwise you
know black can can do something annoying
um he forces the king all the way out
to
the a file and then eventually the key
point here
is that
he gives queen a4 which would be
checkmate if not for knight a5 and
that's the mechanism that he was using
to move the black pieces slowly across
the board
so with that in mind he uses similar uh
you know mechanisms like that to force
uh this position where we finally have
our king over here on h6 we have the
black knight in perfect position and
then from here
he is able to
force the king over to the queen side
using checks to maneuver the bishop to
the perfect position uses a discovered
check again to move the bishop out to h1
and then once again uses a discovered
check with checkmate to force the black
rook over here and then all that's left
to do is bring the king to f6
force the knight to move and we will
have successfully self-made it ourselves
and he does that
quite simply by checking the king over
queen e4 check queen f4 check uh no
nothing to do for black besides take the
queen and checkmate white
so again
i found this on like a pretty shoddy
like pamphlet looking thing on some like
internet archive and probably at some
point in history it got refuted as not
the longest self-made but that is the
longest uh claimed self-made that i
could find out there so if there's any
self-made historians watching the video
let me know what's wrong with william
shinkman's self mate in 418 and if
there's nothing wrong with it
update wikipedia because wikipedia is
wrong
uh okay so hopefully you guys enjoyed
some of these incredibly long chess
puzzles in honor of you know all the fun
puzzles getting published out there for
december uh i had a lot of fun looking
through these and trying to understand
some of the nuances uh and i would love
if you guys at home have some favorite
puzzles that you would like to share as
well but uh these are sort of the limits
of the chess pieces it's hard to make
puzzles that go much longer longer than
this
uh okay with that we've got uh grand
master alex shabalov coming in next to
uh teach insane in the end game
so stick around for that it's probably
going to be a lot more helpful to your
actual chest than this class was but i
wanted to share some of the beauty of
chess
on this tuesday night
okay as always my name is caleb denby
thank you all so much for watching
and i will see you guys next time
[Music]
you